who's coming from
TT thanks jalani thanks to the
organizers for inviting me uh to give a
talk at this Workshop so today I'll be
talking about our joint works on
sketching algorithms for maximum
directed cut and other csps so my main
focus will be on this Max directed cut
problem and I'll briefly try to um
sketch our algorithms for General csps
as
well right let's get started here's the
talk outline for I'll go with the
problem definition and fcor algorithms
and the main bulk of the talk will be on
sketching algorithms for Max dut and the
related lower bounds and then uh if
there's time I'll also talk about
generalizations for arbitrary csps and
um finally I'll conclude with some open
questions let's get started so let me
first Define a closely related CSP which
I'm hoping U we all are familiar with
which is the max cut problem here we are
given an under directed graph and the
task is to find a bipartition that
maximizes the number of edges that go
across the two sets for example in this
case this um bipartition that I just
drew here is um the optimal bipartition
and the cut size is four Max directed uh
sorry and this is called the max cut
size Max directed cut is a related
problem where instead of an undirected
graph you're given a directed graph
again you want uh a bipartition but this
time you want to maximize the edges that
go from let's say a left set to the
right set there's a otion of um
Direction even in the partition and uh
in this example this is the optimal
partition and the dut size is
three okay so okay what are constraints
are disection problems in general so
this is like a very broad definition
that captures problems like Max Cut Max
detected cut which I defined above and
also um lots of other uh optimization
problems um okay let's do just see what
the general structure is so you have
like n variables and you have some um
finite number of constraint types you
can apply on these variables in this
example let's say that you have like two
constraint types and each is of arity K
and what is meant by arity is just that
how many variables each constraint
applies on and there is also a sense of
direction like in the directed graph
like each constraint The Edge
corresponds to a constraint and it says
that here's the in degree and sorry
here's the invertex and the out vertex
something like that you can think about
constraints as being directed and let's
say for example like this red Con in
this instance the red constraint apply
on these three variables blue constraint
applies like this and another red con
let's say this is the
instance now um the goal is to maximize
the number of constraints Satisfied by
finding some partition of the vertexes
so the constraints are uh going to be in
such a way that
um particular assignment of these
variables or for them being in a
particular partition whether they are
satisfied or not is that's how it's
decided for example let's say that the
red constraint says that um if uh your
last variable is yellow then the red
constraint is satisfied and the blue
constraint maybe it's like the variables
must be like yellow pink and orange only
then the B constraint is satisfi so in
this uh particular example if we
consider this partition that I drew
where we are placing these three
vertices in the orange set this vertex
in the yellow set these two vertices in
the pink set then uh the first
constraint the red constraint is going
to be satisfied and the blue constraint
is satisfied but this red this third
constraint won't be satisfied because um
this property is not true and we can see
that um this is actually the best
possible partition and you can only at
the most satisfy two constraints at a
time in this Ty so we would say that the
value of this instance is two because
that's a maximum number of
constraints all right so uh for most
constraint satisfaction problems exact
computation is hard okay uh before that
why are we even like interested in
studying csps so the general structure
allows us to study infinitely many
problems simultaneously this broad
definition like also captures
interesting problems like unique games
Max Kad K and like many interesting
problems and uh it also allows for like
finite classifications through so-called
dichotomy theorems and there are like
several works that study such dichotomy
theorems and in turn this has led to
discovery of new techniques that are
broadly applicable for example STP
rounding Su squares unique games all
this originated from the study of
CSP and um in turn this helps us
understand the power and limitations of
algorithms as a whole and why do we want
to study Max dcut in the streaming
setting so to me the first reason is
that it's just the simplest problem with
non-trivial approximability in the
streaming setting and we'll shortly see
what that means and uh we also were able
to generalize the streaming algorithms
and lower bounds for Max dut to
arbitrary csps the hope is that if we
study optimal algorithms and lower
bounds for Max dut hopefully we can lift
it to all csps and thus obtaining very
GLE algorithms and which is why um my
interest is on studying Max diecut and
then work on generalizations
to okay so this is what I was alluding
to earlier exact computation is of the
optimum value is going to be hard for
most csps so we are interested in
approximation algorithms and let me
Define what an alpha approximation
algorithm is so for a parameter Alpha
the alpha approximation algorithm is one
that outputs a value that's between
Alpha times Optimum and Optimum so if
you notice that I'm not asking for the
optimal assignment itself but I'm asking
only to Output a value that um
approximates the optimal value not
asking for an assignment that has this
corresponding um value and the reason is
because in streaming setting you don't
really have enough space to even like
output your assignment typically so we
are not even going to that goal we're
just asking for you to Output the value
of the CSP instance and not for the
assignment itself
which okay and you can think about an
alpha approximation is an underestimate
that's not you know off by a factor more
than Alpha and this is the definition
for a deterministic algorithm in case of
a randomized algorithm we just want to
Output such an estimate with probability
let's say at least
two it is also typical to study um
approximability of csps through the lens
of Promise problems and uh what are
these promise problems so for every
parameter like beta less than gamma you
want to answer this question can you
distinguish instances with value at
least gamma from uh instances with value
value at most beta so I give you this
promise that it's either this or that
can you um like actually distinguish
these instances why are we interested in
this notion the idea is that if you're
able to answer this question for the
entire range of like beta gamma that's
actually stronger and a finer notion of
approximation corresponding to the
previous one that I talked about for
example if from this I want to conclude
like what's the best possible
approximation I'll do exactly this like
I look at all indistin ible pairs gamma
Beta And if I look at the ratio beta
over gamma that actually gives me like
the optimal Alpha approximation
algorithm that I defined earlier and you
can think about this in terms of the
approximability C for where for every
beta you plot the gamma this is like the
largest gamma that's indistinguishable
from it and then you just look at the
ratio beta or gamma and take the infimo
and that's sort of this approximability
curve is what we want to understand for
csps in any
okay so what are some of the four clor
approximation so for Max cut just a
random dut sorry random cut achieves
half half approximation so if you're
just trying to Output a value just
outputting the number half gives you a
half approximation for Max cut so Random
D cut again achieves 1/4 approximation
and similarly just outputting one over4
gives you one over4
approximation now uh you can also obtain
one minus Epsilon appr oximation this
way where you just like randomly
sparsify your graph or in other words
like you just sample order and like
random edges and if you compute the max
cart or dut value or in general like
even um max CSP value then that um helps
you get one minus Epsilon approximation
so these are some of the forcl
approximations for
csps and now um what are we doing in the
streaming setting in the streaming
setting it's that the edges arrive one
by one in the Stream and then in the end
you're asked to compute the size of the
largest you know in this case largest
dut and that's uh the idea is that you
don't have space to store all your edges
you have very limited space sublinear
space now what kind of good
approximations can you get for the size
of the
largest okay so now I'll talk about the
state-of-the-art we know for Max die cut
and then jump into details of all these
algorithms so let's look at for the
single pass algorithms the state of art
for Max die cut if you plot all the
algorithms that I just discussed so far
so here I mean one is just the if you
want to do the exact computation you can
just do an N square space toward all the
edges if you want to do one minus
Epsilon approximation you can do in like
order and space so um yeah one more
thing is like in I'm plotting space in
the x-axis and ignoring like log factors
and stuff so really you should read this
as like o Tilla square root of n OA n so
on and uh of course with no space you
can get 1/4 approximation which is just
that I don't even look at the stream and
just output one over4 that gives me 1/4
approximation now this is the F Clore so
what's the first result that was known
here so basically you can convert like a
simple reduction helps us get from a Max
cut lower bond to a Max die cut lower
bond which says that you cannot do
better than half approximation in little
low of n space so if you want to beat
half approximation you might as well do
like oneus approximation
and uh this work of R shows that there
is this thing called bias based
algorithm which gives you like some
point4 for approximation but if you want
to beat that you cannot do it in like
little of square root of n
space and uh in a very recent work we
show that in fact if you're given
slightly more than square root of n
space like square root of n log Square n
or something like that we can beat this
point4 for approximation U and get
something better so now the most
interesting open question in this area
is like getting a deeper understanding
of the approximability in this space
like right now we have no clue like if
there is a nice Space versus
approximability tradeoff or anything
like that so that's sort of like the
biggest open question now understanding
this
space okay now let's say that we
consider a setting where the edges
actually arrive randomly ordered the
graph itself is adversarial but the
order in which the edges AR in the
Stream is just like they are randomly
shuffled in this case actually you can
implement the same snapshot algorithm
that we saw before in just like some
polylog space so that s like in random
ordering in just like ilda one space you
have this algorithm that has this 0485
approximation and uh again a Max cut
lower bound uh show like a reduction
from Max cut lower bound shows that you
cannot do better than uh half
approximation in square root of end
space the belief is also that you can
use these techniques and the techniques
from the previous uh work that I showed
in the slide to get even a stronger
lower bond that shows that even in
little of in space you can't do better
than half approximation so here the
biggest question is whether we can
actually approach half approximation in
otia one space or even little of in
space or is there a better lower bound
here so this again this area is like
completely um we don't understand that
and uh for multipass algorithms where
you're allowed multiple passes over the
same set of edges the picture is still
even less clearer than the previous two
settings here so again the snapshot
algorithm that I described before can
actually be implemented in two passes to
get 0486
approximation I just want to pause here
and say like why this result is actually
quite surprising in the sense that if
you look at the very related Max cut
problem it actually the belief is that
even if you're given like like little of
log and passes you shouldn't be able to
beat its um trivial half approximation
or something but for maxut just by
giving an additional pass you're able to
beat the trivial uh like not trivial the
Lo the best log space approximation
algorithm in single pass so it's
[Applause]
sorry so it's
um so that's why this is kind of
interesting because it shows that for at
least for Max diecut even an additional
pass could give you a significant gain
over like single pass uh for this
problem so it's very interesting to
understand like what happens when you
have like subsequent passes can you
approach like half approximation in like
little offense space or
something all right so let's uh for the
rest of the talk I'll uh talk about the
best log space sketching algorithm for
Max diecut talk about the Omega square
root of n space lower bounds and then
all the improved the recent improved
approximations in square root of in
space lock space random ordering and two
passes and if time permits I'll also
talk about generalizations to arbitrary
CSP
yeah wait even for Max cut if if you go
below order end space what's the is this
0 48 thing the BET like your algorithm
applies implies a 0 48 something for Max
cut and is that the best or oh thanks a
lot for the question so um okay the
question is like what is the best known
for Max cut in like little of and space
so for Max C actually like if if I just
give you constant space you get a half
approximation because a random cut gives
you oh right oh Point for8 worse and
half sorry that was an question I
understand okay okay got it no worries
yeah so max good really you can't do it
seems like you can't do anything for Max
cut so that's why we are interested in
studying the max problem um okay
so first I'll talk about like a weaker
approximation problem and this is just
that to kind of motivate what this bias
Bas algorithm does and then I'll talk
about the stronger 49th approximation so
uh okay so let's look at this two5
approximation algorithm so first uh what
is this bias based algorithm so the idea
is that if you look at each vertex and
look at its bias which is just the
difference between it's out degree and
in degree that should pretty much give
you an idea of where to place the vertex
for example if a Vertex only has like
edges going out of it you should just
deterministically place it in the left
set and if a verx only has like edges
coming in you should place it in the
right side that's sort of the high level
idea and here basically this kind of
intuition works is in the sense that if
a Vertex is like positively biased place
it in the left set in your partition and
if it's negatively biased place it in
the right set and it turns out that if I
just take the best of random cut and the
good die cut that gives me a twoth
approximation
this sounds very simple but the thing is
that if you look at it in the streaming
setting you're not going to actually
able to identify which vertices are
positively biased and which vertices are
negatively biased because
[Music]
oops okay so you're not going to be able
to identify which part is are positively
biased and which vertices are positively
negatively biased because you're not
going to be able to store all the
vertices and all the bias and also if
you recall we are not actually asking
for the optimal assignment to all the
vertices rather we are asking only to
for you to Output the optimum value that
you get as a resulting um as a result of
this assignment so now the goal is to
actually compute what this dut value is
that you achieve from best of random dut
and good dut and whether that dut value
can be out puted in the streaming
setting so let's talk about estimation
in log space how we estimate this value
so we Define a quantity called bias of
the graph which is just the L1 Norm of
this bias Vector which is where every
component is just the bias of the vertex
itself now the thing that we show is
that max dcut value is very closely
related to this uh bias of the graph we
give upper bounds and lower bounds in
terms of this bias and um so where the
lower bound comes from the fact that M
over4 if m is the number of edges in the
graph m over4 is just what you get from
a random diecut bias over two is from
good D cut and this is the upper bound
so if you plot this as like upper bound
on Max die cut value in terms of bias
and lower bound then if you look at the
bottle neck is like somewhere here which
gives you a two fif approximation
between the ratio between the upper and
lower bounds that's kind of the high
level idea and how do we compute this
bias itself so it's clear that if you
want to Output the max cyut value all
you need to do is compute the bias but
this is just an L1 Norm of a vector that
is getting updated in the Stream and so
you can you have a log space sketch by
this classic algorithm of indic which
helps you compute the bias of the
[Applause]
gra so now I'll talk a little bit about
why these bounds hold um so for the
upper bound it's just that you have this
simple uh thing that for every vertex
you have at most out degree or in degree
edges in the die cut incident on it so
whether you if you place it in the left
set you lose all the edges that are
incoming and if you place it in the
right set you lose all the edges that
are outgoing so if you just account for
that and do like a simple counting
argument and some rearrangements you get
the lower B sorry upper bound that your
max dut value cannot be Beyond um this
quantity which is 2 M plus 5 over
four okay um so for the lower bound
itself the only thing we need to show is
that the good d cut has value at least
bias or two so this simple argument is
actually due to my advisor former
advisor Madan so um the idea is that
let's say you remove directed Cycles
from the graph this does not change the
bias because for every vertex you lose
um one out Edge and one in Edge so that
shouldn't change the bias of the um the
vertex and in turn the bias of the graph
itself so let's say we remove all the
deded cycles and result in end up in a
dag and in the resulting dag let's keep
removing maximal paths so if you look at
a maximal path it goes from a Vertex
which has like like it goes from a
source to a sync and this has like out
degree greater than in degree and the SN
has in degree greater than out degree so
if you look at a path there should be at
least one Edge such that um on the left
hand point the out degree is like
greater than in degree and the right
hand point the in degree is greater than
out degree other words it will be a good
Edge in the in the Good Die card where
the left end point has greater out
degree and the right end point has
greater in degree so uh this shows that
so each such path decreases the bias by
two but because there exists at least
one Edge in the good dut in this path it
contributes at least one to the value of
the good D cut so by this argument the
good dut should be at least by so
because of these simple reasonings you
have this upper and lower bonds which um
which gives you the two fifth
approximation um now I'll talk about the
49th approximation so for for the 49th
approximation uh we made this
observation that if you look at um
graphs with small bias instead of doing
the like previously we just said that we
take the best of random dut and for this
region 1/4 was the uh value that we were
outputting instead if you look at a
slight ly biased assignments where if uh
the vertex is positively biased place it
in the left set with some biased
probability and negatively bias with
wres it with some bias probability then
U you can actually get a better uh lower
bound on the max diecut value in terms
of bias and that's what's plotted here
in the red curve and this gives us the
49th approximation the surprising thing
is that not just that these values don't
really matter the fact is that this is
also optimal in square root of end space
and what do I mean by that so if you
look at bias it distinguishes instances
like like from the bottom half uh bottom
curve from the instances uh on the top
curve and this shows that in this entire
range this is optimal in the sense that
if I fix some bias I can come up with
two instances in streaming model such
that their values match the upper and
lower bound and they are
indistinguishable in the streaming C so
what this essentially shows is that we
have a dichotomy theorem where if you
look at any parameter these kind of
Promise instances that we were looking
at beta less and Gamma
either if you look at instances of op at
least gamma and instances of op at least
at most beta either their bias values
are separated in which case you just
compute the bias of the instance and you
know which set it belongs to or you
don't have any streaming algorithm that
correctly distinguishes in square root
of nend space so what this means is that
for um the max diecut problem bias is
like all that you can compute in little
of square root of n space which helps
you distinguish instances optimally and
this instiution actually turns out to be
super helpful because in a later work we
showed that this is true for every
single CSP that there's some notion of
bias which is the optimal thing you can
compute for it in like polylog and space
and if you want to beat that
approximation you have to go to like
square root of space so um that's why
this is interesting so uh let me quickly
go over what the approximability curve
is so if this was the um curve that we
saw before where we had this lower bound
and upper bound on Max dut value in
terms of bias and now if I plot it as an
approximability curve where I have again
beta on the x-axis gamma on the y axis
it looks something like this and what we
do is that for this entire range of beta
and corresponding gamma we create
instances such that um the one side
instances match this value and another
side the instances have Max dut value
this but they are inseparable in the
streaming indistinguishable in the
streaming so let's see how that goes so
for streaming lower bounds we typically
use um lower bounds from communication
complexity and in this case we use this
problem called distribution
distributional Boolean hidden partition
so so we use the hardness of this
communication game to obtain a reduction
to show that um d ma Computing Max dut
is also hard in the streaming setting
okay so let's have a like high level
view of like what this problem is so
this is a game where you have like two
kinds of instances and Alice and there
are two players Alice and Bob they don't
know which instance they have and they
have to uh using some minimal
communication be able to uh tell uh one
instance from the other so in the yes
case like Alice gets some random
partition of a graph and Bob gets Union
of some sparse random bipartite graphs
respecting this particular partition so
Bob doesn't have any idea what the
partition is all he sees are just like
some random edges and the promise is
that in one case the edges are going to
like respect the partition and in
another case again Alice gets the same
random partition but um Bob is going to
get some sparse random graph something
that doesn't have to respect any
partition information or something
the idea is that so you want to
distinguish between these two cases i'
say with some good uh constant
probability now but by the birthday
Paradox you can actually solve this
problem in like order rooten um bits of
communication so the goal is like Alice
has to send some bits to Bob and then
Bob has to Output whether or not their
inputs are in the yes case or the no
case so if Alice send some square root
of n um random bits from her thing
saying this vertex is place in the left
side or this vertex in the place in the
right side like information like that
then Bob can use it to actually
determine which case he's in whether he
has a random bipartite graph or just a
random graph now it turns out that this
is actually optimal strategy in the
sense that uh Omega square root of n
Bits in fact is necessary to distinguish
between these two cases and these Works
um essentially show that so now what
we'll do is that we will use this
communication problem and reduce it to
the Max D cut problem for this entire
range of like gamma and um beta that we
saw in the approximability curve before
precisely this so we show that for this
entire range in the yes case we reduce
the instance that Alice and Bob get to
some instance with Max T value T scama
and in the no case it's reduced to
instance
Max okay so how does the reduction work
so assume that they have like a
algorithm streaming algorithm that can
solve the
problem what Bob does is that so when it
h so the idea is that Alice adds some
edges to the portion of the stream and
Bob later adds some edges to the portion
of the stream they run the streaming
algorithm together and then use that to
determine whether or not the max dut
value is um in which U interval that it
belongs to so let me just uh first
describe the edges that Bob does so
because Bob doesn't really have any
information uh a prior about like what
where the vertices are placed and stuff
what Bob does is just simply for every
undirected Edge he has he adds two
directed edges like one going in either
direction so Bob's reduction is veryy
simple what Alice does is something
interesting so what we want to do is
like create instances of like bias B and
definitely Bob cannot do this because
Bob actually doesn't have any idea about
what the partition is so what Alice does
is like let's say that the total number
of edges that Bob is going to create is
M then Alice adds some proportionally so
many edges from like um you know from
this left side to the right side that
she has creating an instance of like
bias B and um the idea is that in one
case in this yes case when Bob has this
bipartition he is actually getting the
yes case is uh Max die cut is at least
scum of B and no case it's PA off Bay
and uh this is actually easier to see in
high bias regions because um for example
let's say we want to show that the no
case Max dut value is at most this then
it's like when bias B little B is really
high it's really alysis edges that
dominate
uh the max die cut value and so this is
turns out to be the optimal partition
which is why in this case like Max die
cut value is same as beta of B which was
this B itself so that's sort of the
intuition but but yeah so this is how
the reduction works and um that's the
separation okay um any questions so
far okay now comes our most recent work
where we show that this is um we can
actually beat this um if just given a
little more than square root of n space
you can beat the optimal 49th
approximation that you saw before and
let's see how we do this so the high
level idea is that you can sketch what
is known as a snapshot of the graph in
order square or OA square root of n
space and use this snapshot to compute
something to basically infer more
information than what just looking at
the bias Vector of the graph would have
given you
so what is this snapshot so let's say
your this is your directed
graph snapshot is something where you
collapse vertices of the same bias into
one big bubble and um basically treat
them all as like the same Vortex or
something so in this case like vortex
one and two have the same bias and so
you collapse them and look at this sort
of like a um like a collapse graph which
is what we call a snapshot and the idea
is that we can like from this snapshot
you can get better approximation and the
snapshot itself can be estimated
in order um like square root of end
space that's sort of the high level idea
and why are these snapshots enough so
there is this interesting work of like f
and Joseph that study so-called
oblivious algorithms for Max diecut in
the in the classical setting so what are
these algorithms so they want to study
those algorithms which are indifferent
between vertices of the same bias
basically these these algorithms you can
think about them as like having only the
snapshot as the input they really they
don't see any anything more about the
graph than the snapshot and they really
have to treat like every vertex of the
same bias in a similar way so uh they
studi these so-called oblivious
algorithms and essentially they show
that you can have these selection
functions which have these um constant
many like bias intervals such that if
you use what is the selection function
doing it is partitioning the entire bias
range um one more thing I'm actually
normalizing this bias um I should have
mentioned this before so you take the
out degree minus in degree and also
divide by the degree so bias is actually
in the range like minus one to one so
you look at all the vertices in in this
range and partition the biases into
various intervals and for every uh
vertex that has bias in a particular
interval you place it in left set with
probability whatever p 0 here and WR set
with probability 1 minus P so you sort
of treat all the ver
not just in like same bias but within
the same bias interval the same way so
that's what a selection function is and
they give us selection function which
has like just constant many intervals
and it achieves like 483 which is bigger
than 49 approximation and they also give
a lower bound that shows that uh you
cannot what no that there's no oblivious
algorithm that can actually beat 4899
approximation I mentioned this here
because if the truth is that you can
actually achieve half approximation in
square root of n space for Max diecut
then this is not the way to go about it
because the lowerbound shows that using
these so-called oblivious algorithms you
cannot really push Beyond 0 4899
approximation so that's another
interesting thing we at the moment we do
not know if in square root of n space
the snapshot computation is the optimal
thing we can do so that would be another
like a very interesting thing to figure
out what's for streaming algorithms
what's the best you can do in square
root of defense space when it comes to
approximating
CS all right now to the actual yes so
this graft that you're creating has
constant SI no the snapshot uh no it
doesn't have con okay if youze it it has
Conant size yes yeah then if you find
the best Max of that gra it's that
0.489
uh I don't think so so that's a good
question no I don't think so no not the
snapshot um if you just compute the max
dut value of the snapshot that doesn't
give you a good approximation yeah yeah
it doesn't snapshot just helps you
compute like um all these yeah basically
you have to do this
um oh yeah snapshot doesn't give you
number you probably haveit yes you
probably have to wait it
but good
question I I think the thing gives you
likeit but that's algorithmic here you
don't con for
okay yeah I'll get back to you the
thanks uh okay so let's talk about how
we even estimate this snapshot in um
streaming model so first we can assume
without loss of generality that the
graph itself is farse because you just
subsample and um you can get one minus
Epsilon approximation so we might as
well assume the input graph is spars now
let's actually talk about the random
ordering algorithm which is quite simple
so you just take the first order one
edges and store the induced subgraph and
track the biases of the vertices this
helps you compute the snapshot because
um you just need this constant as sepher
pointed out the snapshot itself is of
like constant size and then you just
need constant many edges to estimate the
snapshot itself
and um if you're doing two passes then
again
it's it's like a straightforward
extension from this algorithm because
you just use the first pass to sample
constant many random edges and the
second pass you basically do this whole
thing of storing the indu sub graph and
tracking the bias of the Ys the
algorithm is actually quite simple when
it comes to like random ordering and two
passes and even for bounded degree
graphs so the idea is that we want to
actually get random edges but in
adversarial ordering you don't have
random edges and the closest thing you
can do is actually sample random
vertices and look at the induced
subgraph and if you hope is that if you
sample enough number of random vertices
then you can apply concentration bounce
to um get to approximate the snapshot
well and it turns out that if you're
looking at bounded degree graphs square
root of n vertices
suffices so so far all good simple but
bounded degree assumption is really
crucial for this algorithm because let's
say I have the star graph I mean it
could have Max D cut value one and if
I'm just going to sample square root of
an random vertices it's I'm not likely
to see this middle vertex so when I like
track um just the induced subgraph on
that uh on the sampled vertices I'm not
going to be able to see this uh middle
Vortex itself and that's not going to
give me enough information about uh what
the max tyut value is so we do something
uh more intricate for arbitrary graphs
so we do this thing called layered
sampling of vertices where in our final
graph we want to see like some kind of
uniform sample from every degree class
or something so what we do is like we
partition the entire degree range into
login uh many intervals and then we try
to sample get a uniform sample of
vertices in each degree interval and
store the induced subgraph there so um
the idea is that we want to sample let's
say vertices of degree D with
probability D over square root of n so
for vertices with degree higher than um
square root of n you just basically end
up storing all of them and for other
vertices it's like d over square root of
n can check that they still make sure
that the space is only like upper
bounded by square root of N and they
still the
factors but of course the challenge is
that when you see a Vertex you have no
idea what the degree of the vertex is so
it's not that I can look at the vertex
and say oh hey it belongs to this
interval let me sample it with this
probability do or square root of N and
place it or something so that's the
challenge first challenge that we do not
know the degree of the vertex when it
first appears so we do something else we
actually do a layered sampling of the
edges and use that to sample vertices
for example let's say that I look at my
graph and subsample edges with
probability 1
/d then
only first of all you're only likely to
see in this new graph or the edges are
going to be incident only on vertices
which have degree at least D in the
original graph and um they also you
expect them to have degree roughly order
one in the um subsample graph so the
idea is that you look at um first the
subsample edges and then subsample
vertices with the desired probability if
ignore those vertices which have degree
like much uh larger than constant or
much more smaller and you're not even
likely to see many such vertices which
have like degree much less than
constant and
um okay any
[Applause]
questions and what is the issue here so
you can still misclassify vertices
especially those at the boundaries of
the degree intervals and place them
either in the left interval or in the
right interval by mistake you could also
potentially make errors in bias
computation if you look at the previous
algorithms like you just sampled a
random edges or random vertices you knew
beforehand which kind of vertices you're
going to be keeping track of so you
actually compute the biases exactly so
in the snapshot estimation you don't
make any mistake in the bias computation
itself here you could also mess that up
if they're in the boundary the bias the
bias the vertices could be placed the
left interval or the right interval even
in the biases so you could have such
issues as well so how we handle that is
by doing some smooth estimate of the
snapshots so what's a refined snapshot
is just that originally our question was
like how many edges go from some bias
interval to another bias interval now we
also like do this fine grain thing of
like bias interval bi some degree
interval DJ to bias interval BK and like
some degree interval DL or something so
we just this is just a more refined
notion if I just like want to compute
from bias interval bi to BK I just sum
over all the degrees so I can still get
the original snapshot I want from this
refined snapshot now what is the smooth
snapshot we look at the average of these
entries of this Matrix over a window of
size
w
so uh wait
so what do you say does it also apply to
like their degrees being Logan or
something
other the
edges
bigger function
uh overall it takes square root of n
space uh
[Applause]
okay
okay matching still
look oh it's oh it's sub yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah I'm not storing all of them yeah
sorry I should have been clearer yeah
not storing the whole graph
yeah yes I further subsample them and
store only the sub
sample yes thanks great question yeah um
okay okay so we do this so because
it's the it you could actually make if
you're trying to compute the refined
snapshot itself and get a pointwise good
estimate of it you're not going to be
able to actually get because with high
probability you're going to make errors
misclassifying these degrees and biases
so we ask for like a weaker thing where
I'm only looking at like an average of
this entry over a window of size W in
this case let's say window of size one
in the sense that I don't care if you
misclassify things up to like one
because I'm taking this average just
give me this average correctly and if
you take larger and larger window sies
the boundaries shouldn't hurt you much
because you're taking the average so
that's sort of the idea that you can
compute this smooth snapshot efficiently
and you should get better and better
estimates as you increase the window
size then um but then the question is
like how is this helping you for example
if I take like very very big window
sizes I'm not going to even like
resemble this refined snapshot in any
way so from the smooth snapshot I mean
if I'm taking just the average of all
the entries in The Matrix I'm just going
to get like value one or something and
that's not giving you any information so
this thing is that you have to hit the
right balance like you cannot have very
large window size at the same time if
you have too small of a window size also
you get uh bad estimat so sort of you
are able to hit the right side thing and
you get the
um correct thing that helps you U
approximate this refined snapshot
question is like why do these smooth
snapshot even survice how do we get
information uh about the refine Snapshot
from it basically the question is why
don't misclassification errors matter in
this sense so degree if you notice that
degree misclassification errors do not
actually affect snapshot computation
this is because let's say there is no
error in the bias computation but
there's only error in the degree
computation ultimately you're going to
look at your snapshot somewh all the
degrees anyway and then um compute the
actual snapshot so it doesn't matter if
you actually misclassify the degrees so
we don't have to this is why we don't
have to actually compute the refined
snapshot itself just Computing the
smooth version is enough whether you sum
over the smooth version or you sum over
the refined version degree
misclassifications are not going to hurt
you you're going to get the same value
now bias misclassification errors do not
affect Max dut value when the window
size is small this is because what is
bias misclassification error mean like
instead of like declaring your value of
the bias as B you're like declaring it
as B plus or minus Epsilon so what
happens is that a vert you can think
about it as like perb in this sense that
instead of it you seeing it as a bias B
vertex you look at it as a bias B plus
or minus Epsilon vertex now the idea is
that you are able to perturb the
original graph to get a new graph with
similar dcut value such that if you look
at the smooth snapshot of G it
corresponds to a refined snapshot of
this new graph H so in that sense you're
trying to estimate like the max dcut
value based on the smooth snapshot and
you might as well think about it as
estimate the input being H and
estimating the max stut value of this
refined snapshot so because the
algorithm works on refined snapshot it
should also give you within plus minus
Epsilon errors the approximation for the
smooth snap shot and the idea is very
simple if the bias is off by Epsilon you
just create a new isolated vertex and
modify this bias by creating at most
Epsilon d new edges and overall this
shouldn't change your max start cut
value by more than Epsilon M so your max
I cut value isn't changing by more than
Epsilon
function
that's how many minutes do I have do I
have time to talk about 14 minutes okay
great so maybe I'll also talk about
generalizations to arbitrary csps
because hopefully this will motivate why
we even want to understand the max dut
picture in more detail and hopefully
that will also help us understand
csps in this case I'll talk about our
dichotomy theorum for arbitrary csps in
the space of like poly log n versus like
square root of n so this is like a
generalization for um csps where we show
that there is this General notion of
bias which you can use to like um do
this login approximation for general
csps or any sketching algorithm so our
bound is weaker here we do not pro a
lower bound against streaming algorithms
all we show is that if you have a
sketching algorithm then that cannot
distinguish uh between instances that
cannot be distinguished by bias
essentially and um at a very high level
the dichotomy theorem looks like this
where corresponding to every gamma beta
we Define these convex sets uh which we
call
like gamma beta sets and if these sets
are like separated then bias can
actually distinguish between gamma
instances from beta instances and if not
we show that you cannot distinguish them
in like little of Square Ro of in space
and to note that these are like actually
convex close and bounded sets in some
finite dimensional space and so this is
actually a decidable condition you give
me a gamma beta and the truth table for
the um for the function for the CSP then
I can tell you in P space whether or not
the these things are separated or um
there is some lower bound showing that
these instances cannot be separated
that's like a very high level view of a
dichotomy theorum and I'll talk a little
bit about like the structure of the bias
so you can uh look at the bias of the
max like C um graphs and you can like
rewrite them this way where think of
this as a bias Matrix where it captures
like the marginal information about
every workex basically it captures the
outdegree and in deegree of every vertex
and uh this is the expression for the
bias where you're asking for the um like
the L1 Norm of the differences between
the in degrees and out degrees we can
think about these as like some sort of
weights and this is Computing like um
sort of how important like each
coordinate is and how you have to assign
your
values now the idea is that for at least
Boolean csps when you have like gamma
beta that are distinguishable you can
choose a suitable set of Weights instead
of like one minus one this bias Matrix
still just says that how many
constraints are there with let's say
variable XJ in the ith position and U so
that is just like a general ization of
this bias Matrix you see here and this
weights just tells you like roughly how
important each coordinate is and the
bias is again the same thing where
you're Computing the L1 Norm of this
whole quantity and this turns out to be
the general bias notion that helps us
like distinguish um
distinguish and even for arbitrary csps
we have even more General let's take a
very very very high level look of like
how does this bias work so we we defined
some yellow and red sets before and said
that when they are separated you can use
bias to distinguish the instances else
you cannot
so thing is that these yellow and blue
set sorry red sets are defined in the
following way if your Optimum so these
are in K dimensional space where K is
the arity of the constraint satisfaction
problem and if the optimum value of your
instance is at least gamma then there
exists some assignment a such that this
quantity that you see here ba a
transpose is in the yellow set and if
Optimum is at most beta for every
assignment ba transpose is in the red
set so this is how these things are
defined and now when you look at let's
say that Lambda corresponds to the
normal of the separating hyper plane if
these two sets are um actually do not
intersect then if you look at this
quantity which is like like Max of you
know in a product of Lambda Gamma beta
with ba transpose in one case it should
give you bias that at least which is
what I call the bias one case this inner
product should be at least St because of
the separating hyperplan theorem and
another case this should be at most
because every assignment this ba
transpose is in this red
side um so yeah and what happens when
they intersect when they intersect it's
the same idea as what we have had
previously for the max die cut in the
sense that you can create two instances
with the same bias Matrix and we show
that when you have two instances from
this region like gamma and beta such
that their bias matrices exactly match
then there is nothing you can do in the
streaming setting and you can't separate
them in square root of and space again
Lower bounds follow from hardness of
communication and the nice thing about
these lower bounds and streaming is that
they're unconditional because they
follow from information thetic uh
part okay so that sort of concludes my
talk and some open questions I think the
most interesting question for Max dut
now is just understanding if we can
achieve H half approximation in like
sublinear space random ordering multiply
setting whatever like whether we can
like actually get to this best half and
uh the next question is that now we have
uh can we have dichotomy theorems in
sublinear space for example our first L
of snapshots actually optimal in square
root of end space this would mean that
you cannot achieve half approximation in
square root of n space but maybe you can
still achieve it in sub linear space and
if for snapshots are actually optimal um
can we also like generalized this to
other csps and show something like even
for them there's some general notion of
a start a snapshot that can be used to
get the optimal approximability in but
uh that's about it thanks a lot for your
attention thank
you
questions thank you very much H just one
quick question I just want to understand
the bias in the arbitrary csp's
definition for example the CSP you had
that let's say the last ver let's say we
have three ver three R
R3 constraints and we want the last like
the example you show the last vertex to
be yellow or something how would the and
I give you some sort of graph on top of
that how would
the bias uh look like in this example oh
that's a good question thanks so one
thing I didn't um I sort of skimmed over
is that when I Define bias here I assume
that I only have like one type of
constraint so if you're one type of one
type of constraint if you have more
constraint then you have like another
dimension there for like a layer of by
you can think of it as a tensor for
every constraint uh every type of
constraint you have like a bias Matrix
that you have and so it's like a tensor
but but yeah in your question if you
just have one type of constraint I can
forget that because it's the same
constraint that's applied on all sets of
you know variables so all I asked for is
like how many constraints are there with
my variable let's say XJ in this
particular position and that's all this
information but that's just sorry I
should have made it clear I'm assuming
in this definition that it's just like
one I see I see see okay thank thanks
thanks thanks question
questions for
sying I get the image of the separating
hyperplane correctly so in this space
like what are the vectors which I would
for instance think about as being like
orthog on one side or other side of the
hyperplane like what do I check again so
that makes sense uh let
[Applause]
me just the
thing yes so are you talking about
vectors what these vectors are in the
space or yeah so for instance you said
like in PS space we're able of like
distinguishing which case were in or
something like this right oh so we're
like there's some notion of like there's
these vectors which we can like
computationally compare against and what
is the space of these vectors that be
looking at oh that's a very good
question thanks so so it actually looks
like like you can whether these two sets
intersect or not can be actually
expressed like as a in the Quantified
theory of reals you can say something
like there exist blah for all such that
this polinomial has some root or
something like that and which is why
like you can actually like um um do it
in P space so okay actually definition
is a little more intricate I'll be happy
to take it offline but but but the
reason why it's p space because the just
the question of whether these two sets
which I haven't even defined which is
why it's a little to explain what I mean
but this decidability Criterion can be
expressed using this Quantified theory
of reals which is just bunch of
quantifiers and asking whether some
polinomial has a root or not and then um
that itself can be computed in cool
thank you okay
thanks I I have a question about like
the dependence on the bias so if the
bias is zero like if your graph is
essentially undirected then you get back
Auto automatically to this like five
approximation because you just don't
need to even estimate the and then like
your lower bounds do they hold even when
the like in the instances of the lower
bounds do they hold does the bias need
to be quite large like some constant or
like it's oh it holds yeah that's a very
good question thanks but it holds in the
entire range because if bias is zero
what happens is that Alice doesn't even
add any edges right right so then in one
case you have this random directed graph
which gives you 1/4 approxim
in another case you have a random bipar
graph but edges going in both Direction
which gives you Max dut value half even
those are inseparable so even when bias
is zero for the special case you ask we
give a lowerbound that you cannot do
better than half approximation just by
but I guess what I mean then is like so
if bias is 0.001 or something then your
lower bound would be like 0499 but you
have this lower bound you had this
General lower bound of like
048 for this for less than root n right
or was I confused right so okay
like does that require the bias to be
large or uh so the lower bound itself
works in the entire range of
bias so this is is this the slide that
you're referring to yeah maybe yes so
for this entire range of bias you can
see that okay so if we sit and compute
what the max dut value of this uh
distribution is for smaller B it's like
so this no value is the weirder thing
like here you're going to have you just
have to give one good partition which
turns out to be this like planted
partition itself which gives you this
max dcut value always like matching this
curve which is not part but for here
it's kind of intricate in the sense that
when bias is Big this is the partition
that dominates like this turns out to be
the best partition which is why your um
graph looks like this but when bias is
like tiny like this is not the optimal
partition you actually have to like look
at like sort of the a random partition
and that sort of um gives you this like
curve that you see here yeah I see okay
so yes you get it in the entire range um
that um they match like yeah yeah they
just matches that and no matches that
it's just little bit more intricate in
the low bias region but it's it's just
basically Computing the max diecut value
of this okay I get it yeah
thanks
um so in the random order setting for
one minus Epsilon and exact are the
current known lower bounds like just the
same as the 1 half is there anything
better than
that uh yeah right now I think the for
random monitoring I mean the best known
lower bound officially I I should also
talk to like Mike Michael about it we
just had this conversation so official
known lower bound is like square root of
n space you cannot do better than half
but definitely Michael believes that you
can do like even in little offens space
You shouldn't be able to do better than
half by combining the techniques from
adversary ordering and the other square
root of n space lower Bound for random
ordering I haven't verified it but I I
believe so so if you want to do one
minus Epsilon
approximation belief is that you might
have to go beyond n space which is which
is anyway even in the adversary in you
know how to do 1s Epsilon so so yeah I
mean so for random moding at least like
the goal now would be to get to this
half approximation which would be very
nice thank you
thanks questions for
S then let's thank her one more time
thank you so
[Applause]
much